yesterday
aoc go to aoc's twitter account i don't
know if she's already twitted 40 other
things we're not going to be able to
find it
but just go on twitter type in aoc go to
her uh yeah go straight to her
uh let's see what we got here keep going
up keep going up keep going up keep
going up there and martin luther
okay here's here's the message that you
have uh go go up one go up one
so she said this martin luther king was
murdered in front of concern today's gop
we are
gutting the very voting rights act king
worked for you don't want to believe
something you know something does it go
up one more like mind if i click on that
one right there the bottom one the one
that says whites it must be frankly said
okay go
up she says something else on the bottom
keep going right there
the quote of king is not from an early
work it is from one of his last words
where do we go from here chaos or
community
uh if all sorts of folks who claim what
mlk would do actually studies at work
they would understand he was a radical
and an anti-capitalist too you know
what's crazy
she says that now go to my twitter
account go to my twitter account and i
retweeted her and i had my thoughts to
say about this year
okay go up and let me see where it's at
there you go
while the world is witnessing the people
of cuba protests against socialism and
communism you trash capitalism
terrible timing to bash capitalism
especially when your ultimate capital is
using your platform to sell 20
sweaters for 60 right so the point is
she has a platform to trash capitalism
young innocent naive people who have
never lived in cuba who have never lived
in iran who have never lived in a
communistic regime before
look at that and say oh my gosh she
knows what she's talking about words
have a lot of power and today these
words are influencing the younger
audience to say
capitalism sucks rich people suck
socialism is the way to go right that's
the direction we want to kind of
pitch america to go the good news is
that we're starting to see people like
ashton kutcher mcconaughey some of these
other guys just saying i don't know if
that's the direction we want to go
hopefully those people will rise up more
and they'll push back some of these
initiatives i
there's gonna come a time next 10 or 20
years when she's going to run for
president
and i've already told you what my belief
system is what percentage it is
the day she becomes a president folks be
ready this is all i'm going to tell you
the day she becomes a president she is
going
if you fast forward between now and 20
years from now how many followers you
think aoc is going to have in 20 years
it's right now she's got 12 and a half
million
what do you think she's going to have in
10 years 50 million what are you talking
about
in 10 years how many followers do you
think she'll have 150 probably
she's probably going to be 150 million
follower person
passing agenda like this what do you
think is going to be the chance of a
running
very very high brace for impact
i had one of my employees i was speaking
to him i said so uh uh
house family house kids how's this he
says you know what my wife and i made
one decision what's that
we're not gonna have kids so why not i
said to be honest with you we talked to
the family about this
this is a conservative family i said why
are you not having kids he says
pat with everything that's going on
today why have kids
when we know whatever we do to raise the
kids the school the media everybody is
trying to shape their way of thinking
that we can't win that battle
did you see the video that i said i
don't know by the way i think that's a
horrible perspective
it's not i don't know who said that but
it's it's not i think that's a i think
that's
the decision a couple has yeah that's
fine i don't know who said it i don't
know why they said it
is a i think that's a cop-out first of
all i'm having four kids you think i'm
sitting there agreeing with the guy what
i'm trying to tell you is the fact that
people are afraid of having kids
because they're worried about how
dangerous it is right now like
if if right now if right now you know in
the next 10 or 20 years a person like
aoc is going to be president you excited
about it
no i wouldn't be excited about it but
that wouldn't prevent me from having
kids
not saying it's like a doomsday scenario
he's like a prepper whoever that is is
like a prepper
not you but there are a lot of people
who are educated smart people
who are worried about what the future
looks like the only reason somebody's
not having kids today is because they're
worried about the next 10 20 30 years
look i get the guy's perspective i mean
look yesterday
i'm flying here and uh you know i get
married i don't get it i guess
a week ago my daughter asked me my
daughter ivan asked hey dad you think
we're gonna have to wear masks next year
at school i said no way
look at california's open right now it
feels normal everything's great there's
no way yesterday
they announced mass are mandatory and
then they did it about face later
i think and they said that every school
district's gonna be able to make that
decision i was so depressed when i heard
that i mean they're coming after these
kids again
they've already robbed a year and a half
of their life literally they've taken it
from that the kids are going to get it
back
yeah well of course they are going back
to school they are going back to school
and they were not in school like your
kids were not in school at all last year
in california
they were they didn't go back to school
until april and then it was like one or
two hours a day one or two days a week
but at least for right now school
doesn't start till august september yeah
the plan is they're going back full time
but
they better not be wearing masks that's
all i can say but but california can
impose that on them if they wanted to
it's that simple california can't say
you know they're going to be
uh not wearing mask or wearing masks
having to do that they have nothing to
say you can't say nothing
about that at all so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye